tu vas en boîte quelle boîte mais
fallait me dire je vais me préparer je
vais t'accompagner tu vas pas aller
toute seule non on vient te chercher qui
c'est qui vient te chercher
un type qu'est-ce qui comment il
s'appelle qu'est-ce qu'ils font les
parents mais écoute-moi bien fortuné
moi je sais exactement comment ça se
passe avec les types de ce type
une fois en boîte il va vouloir te payer
un verre
et ben tu dis oui et après il va vouloir
t'inviter à danser
et ben tu dis OUI tu vas tu danses
qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu peux t'éclater
non
après il va vouloir te ramener mais il
va pas se garer devant la maison il va
se garer sans mettre plus loin et il va
vouloir te toucher la poitrine oui ma
fille oui il va vouloir te toucher la
poitrine
et ben tu dis oui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu peux t'éclater
aussi non mais pas trop hein fortuné
parce que les fruits une fortement les a
touchés plus personne veut les acheter